and Sharon opens up about his secret
struggle with substance abuse for me my
problem is a very difference in someone
else's in a new interview on the
Jonathan Ross show airing on Saturday
the 26 year old singer says he had a
tough time adjusting to fame when he
started in the music industry he said
quote I didn't adjust because I was
constantly working on tour all the
pitfalls that people read about I just
found myself slipping into all of them
mostly like substance abuse I live a
very very fortunate but very surreal
life and getting caught up in that
surrealist
can be damaging I think ed admits he did
notice the unhealthy habits were getting
the best of him until his colleagues
called him out about it
quote it all starts off as a party and
then you're doing it on your own and
it's not so that was a wake-up call and
taking a year off during his year-long
hiatus the shape of you singer focused
on his music and credits his longtime
girlfriend
Shari Seaborn for bringing balance into
his life something he told ET in March
was a part of his major lifestyle change
I just started living a healthier
lifestyle you know I change smokes I
drunk a lot a lot of alcohol and ate
very unhealthy and I just kind of cut
70% of that out I still do all those
things they're just not in excess my dad
said anything in moderation so yeah I
just basically just needed to moderate
[Music]